what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with Marvel's secret Invasion
yes we are doing the coverage of the
story as always we will have a playlist
down in the description which will have
all the secret Invasion videos so you
guys can keep track of the videos as
they come out uh and you'll never have
to worry about getting lost with all the
videos that we make and there's a couple
things we need to specify one this is
where everything picks up right this is
where the story starts getting really
really good the other thing that we have
to keep in mind though is that this part
that we're going to cover here with Nick
Fury takes place before the events of
Civil War and we'll explain why that
matters here in a second but Nick Fury
is basically underground now all this is
really the aftermath of a story called
fury secret War which is basically where
Nick Fury launched an unsanctioned
attack against Liberia which was not
ruled by Dr Doom at the time but because
it was unsanctioned and things basically
went South It ultimately led to him
being kicked out as director of shield
and then a warrant being put out for his
arrest after which point he just kind of
disappeared he just went underground
which is where he's at right now but the
other thing about this is that this also
deals with the arrival of Valentina
right like can and Tessa Valentina you
guys know her from the Marvel Cinematic
Universe because she's being played by
Julia Louise Dreyfus in the comics her
and Nick Fury have had a kind of
on-again off-again romantic relationship
and if anything it was really one out of
necessity right they were both basically
just pumping each other for information
but both were kind of on board with it
because I guess they just wanted a bank
but one of the things that Contessa
reveals is that in the aftermath of fury
secret war that Maria Hill has been
promoted to director of shield and
everybody who knows Nick Fury has
basically been suspended indefinitely
from Shield The Only Exception being
dumb dumb Dugan just because of the fact
that he was Fury's right hand man and
it's better to have Dum dumdogan on
board because Dugan's alliances are to
Fury but they're also doing the right
things so he could kind of go either way
but the thing about this is that of
course the two of them end up spending
the night together and then when they
wake up the next morning Contessa tells
Fury she's gonna go get breakfast now
one of the things to know about Nick
Fury because in Marvel Comics what you
have right now is you've got like the
black guy Nick Fury right Samuel Jackson
Nick Fury or Nick Fury Jr as they call
him this is back in the day when you had
like the old white guy Nick Fury and so
what this means is that this version of
Nick Fury was always suspicious of
everybody and he would literally just
stay suspicious until you gave him a
reason not to now a lot of that's just
because of his time fighting in World
War II with the Howling Commandos
becoming a CIA agent then become
director of Shield that kind of a thing
so his life is literally just mired in
war and and suspicion and the result of
this is that when Contessa leaves he
activates a device on his wrist that
allows him to bend light around him
making him invisible and then follows
her and what he realizes is she's
actually meeting with somebody who
appears to be part of just some group
out there that maybe has it out for Nick
Fury or whatever the case is but the
kind of things they're saying confirm
the suspicions of Fury when they're
saying things like will I have his trust
give me time and I'll get the
information we need so on and so forth
but obviously this is either not
Contessa or Contessa is working and
turning against Fury and is likely going
to try to turn him over into some
capacity and so when she arrives Nick
Fury is already ready he's literally got
a gun in his hand he's sitting in a
chair and he's like who are you really
and of course one of the things to know
about Fury is he'll ask that question a
couple times if Nick Fury asked you that
question who are you really assume it's
rhetorical assume he already knows the
answer that you're not who you claim to
be and where she tries to sort of Dodge
and Bob and weave and like what are you
doing Put the gun down like that kind of
a thing he literally is just like one
more time who are you really and he's
showing no signs that like he kind of
believes her or she's getting him to let
his guard down you know it's one of
those things where he's like who are you
really and when she doesn't answer the
question he immediately shoots her and
she turns into a scroll and that's what
when Marvel basically confirms Nick Fury
is the first one to figure out that
scrolls are invading Earth he's the
first one to find out what happens now
in terms of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe that's probably going to end up
happening with Samuel Jackson he's gonna
be the first one to realize what's going
on so they're basically taking the
element of this story and carrying it
over to the MCU regarding his character
but following that he basically goes to
a rooftop he spies on the guys that the
scroll was meeting with and he realizes
they're speaking in a scroll dialect so
he's like okay she's not the only one
one it's not a one-off right like there
are multiple Scrolls on earth now the
question is what do they want and so
what he ends up doing is he actually
breaks into the shield Helicarrier like
its main base of operations and when he
gets in he starts talking to like Maria
hill now that's the other thing about
Nick Fury Nick Fury was ridiculously
capable and it's kind of funny because
he basically knows Shield inside and out
because a lot of the systems that Shield
uses he developed or had them developed
for shield so he literally knows all the
back doors he knows how to sneak in and
even when Shield went back and modified
the systems because obviously why would
you move into a house and never change
the locks when the previous owner leaves
that even all of that Nick Fury is so
capable he can still get in undetected
that's just how good he is as an agent
right he's just that capable and so
Maria Hill is initially taken off guard
but Nick Fury does not come here to
provoke a fight he comes here to
basically tell her there's some things
you need to do right because remember
this takes place before Civil Wars so
for those of you guys who are unfamiliar
with what that means during the events
of Civil War because Maria Hill had
effectively just bungled the entire
superhero conflict and because she
operated with two extreme of a hand in a
lot of ways it was her feeling
underestimated by the people around her
so she was just over compensating and
torpedoed her career in the process that
Tony Stark ends up becoming the new
director which is actually what you'll
find when we transition into the next
part of the story in this video but the
thing about this is that at this point
in time she's the head of Shield right
she's the one running the show and so
that's why Fury is like now that you
have this gig now that you have this job
Fury one already knows she's not a
scroll right he's looked into her and
we'll find out how he does that here in
a second but he basically already looked
into her he knows that it's actually
Maria Hill he literally tells her you're
surrounded on all sides by people who
have it out for you I.E Nick Fury saying
there are a ton of Scrolls on this ship
he's not telling her their Scrolls but
he's like there's a ton of people here
who are who have it out for you and it's
only a matter of time before they make
that move against you number two
whenever you have that itch on the back
of your neck that feeling of uncertainty
that's your gut talking to you learn to
trust it learn to believe that and what
you need to do is start developing life
model decoys make like a dozen of those
things right and just start sending them
out whenever you're unsure about what's
going on whenever you get that little
feeling on the back of your neck and
your your gut is telling you something's
off send a life model decoy in your
stead and the last thing he says is like
I'm gonna be watching you I'm gonna be
keeping an eye on you and if any point
along the line I think you're not who
you really are I'll kill you on spot
right like basically if she's replaced
by a scroll I will take you out and so
Maria Hill has no idea what Nick Fury is
talking about but one of the things to
notice here is that while her loyalties
are to shield and while she does does
basically activate a code white which is
the highest level code they have
available like basically this is like an
immediate coming together of Shield
agents everybody mobilize take out that
Target right just like oh my God like
it's a great big huge thing does she
also understand the importance of Nick
Fury she also understands the
significance of Nick Fury and he would
not break into the shield Helicarrier
headquarters risk getting caught even
though it was never going to happen just
to convey those messages to Maria Hill
so she can ignore it right like it's one
of those things where she literally
takes it to heart hurt and so what you
end up doing is of course Nick Fury just
kind of disappears right he literally
just activates a beacon that basically
makes him invisible to not only the
human eye but as well as radar so they
just don't know where he went to he just
vanishes like like a fart in the wind
and so he ends up meeting with Spider
Woman Jessica Drew now one of the things
to know here about Spider Woman is that
she was initially brought in by Nick
Fury and she's effectively a spy
initially she was a spy that basically
worked on behalf of Nick Fury
infiltrating Hydra and then she was a
spy for shield which is what she is
right now but she ends up becoming kind
of a triple agent basically working for
Nick Fury in the sense that she was
spying on Hydra that's no longer a thing
anymore we'll talk about that here in a
minute she is currently a shield agent
but of course they're highly suspicious
of her because of her history with Nick
Fury now Nick Fury basically approaches
her and is like I need you to spy on
shield and I need you to spy on the
superheroes right unlike the Avengers in
those groups and report back to me
anything you find now one of the things
that Nick Fury also reveals and the way
that he kind of monitors Spider-Woman
and knows that Spider Woman is not a
scroll is that he's basically been
keeping an eye on her for two weeks he's
literally just been watching her this
whole time watching her movements
watching her comings and goings
everything and it's kind of a funny
thing because Nick Fury is just that
suspicious of everybody he meets but
when she starts asking him questions
like why do you want me to spy on
superheroes and shield and you're
basically turning me into a triple agent
the response to Fury is because it's a
much bigger thing and that's all that I
can tell you but again it's one of those
situations where when Nick Fury shows up
on your doorstep and says I need you to
do something for me you usually assume
it's for the greater good because Nick
Fury never really does anything for
extremely selfish motivations he never
really does anything to just cover
himself up right and so ultimately
because of the respect she has for Nick
Fury that Spider Woman gets on board and
so what this does is it transitions over
to a regathering of the Illuminati now
this is when we talk about kind of the
bigger picture anybody who's read
anything online about secret Invasion
most all of you have heard somewhere
along the line the idea that the
superheroes learned about secret
Invasion because it turned out Elektra
was a scroll so that happened in a new
Avengers store he was a five-part story
and we can cover it if you want to but
it has nothing to do with anything until
you get to like the last two or three
pages when Elektra dies when the new
Avengers launch an assault on the hand
which is like a mystical ninja
organization and when Electra dies she
turns into a scroll that's all you
really have to know right following that
basically what had happened is Spider
Woman had taken the body of Elektra to
Iron Man and was like what in the hell
is going on like what is this like why
do we have a scroll on The Avengers team
what's happening here and so with Iron
Man having no idea what was going on
with that he basically brings the body
of Elektra to a new Gathering of the
Illuminati and when they all come
together they don't even know what's
going on right like like Iron Man's the
only one that knows what's happening and
in fact even when Namor shows up Neymar
believes it's the body of Captain
America because this segment takes place
after the events of Civil War and even
after the death of Captain America which
was not technically part of Civil War
But ultimately the Iron Man's like no
this is a scroll and so it's kind of
like okay like how did a scroll
Infiltrate The New Avengers and that's
the question of Tony Stark is I don't
know like we don't know like we didn't
even know she was a scroll nobody knew
she was a scroll right like what's going
on here when it comes to the new
Avengers there's two people on that team
who would have immediately picked up on
the fact that she was a scroll the first
was Peter Parker's spider scent and even
if Peter didn't know exactly what was
going on because every time Spider-Man
looked at a lecture his spider since
would have gone off even though it just
would have seemed weird maybe Electro
had it out for him he would just kind of
be suspicious with Wolverine and all of
his enhanced senses he would have
immediately been able to pick up on the
fact that's not Elektra but for whatever
reason and by whatever means the Scrolls
can evade that the Scrolls can literally
Dodge Spider-Man so it never goes off
and Wolverine's senses never detect that
they're not who they claim to be and so
it's one of those things where it's like
okay how did this start and that's when
Iron Man's like were the ones who did it
like how do you think it started weak
cause this and so of course this
references the last video we did which
of course again you're welcome to check
out the playlist in the description so
you can keep track of it all so you
won't get lost with all the videos we
make here on the channel but in that
video we talked about about how when the
Illuminati first formed the first thing
they did was show up to the scroll
Homeworld and basically tell them if you
bring your war with a Cree close to
Earth like that again we will annihilate
all of you and the response to the
Scrolls basically took them captive and
then started basically working on their
genes or trying to find a way to
understand their genes and then at a
future point in time when the scroll
world was destroyed by Galactus that the
Scrolls began the process of replacing
superheroes on Earth and so were the
members of the Illuminati are kind of
full of hubris and are just sort of like
no man like all we did was go there and
warn them and that kind of a thing Iron
Man's like no we caused this like we're
the reason why this happens we can't
tell anybody that right we can't tell
anybody that we're the reason this this
whole thing happened but at the end of
the day we're the reason behind it all
now the other thing that's kind of
interesting here is a lot of members of
the Illuminati are kind of like okay
well what if it's just one like what if
what if it's just a scroll like a rogue
scroll that defected from the empire for
whatever reason and basically just took
over you know just replaced Electra
right like which by the way where is the
real Electra and it's kind of like I
don't know she's missing or she's dead
like I have no clue she is all I know is
like she's just the Elektra here right
that's Iron Man's response like it's
just the scroll that we see in front of
us but the other thing that Iron Man
says is like this is the one we found
but we have to assume there's more we
can't just look at this Electra scroll
and see it here and say well we'll we'll
worry about it if it happens some more
we have to assume that there are more
Scrolls that are that have infested
Earth in some capacity and so as a
result of that basically the entire
reality of the situation hits home when
you have this discussion or really this
moment where black bull which is
probably one of the the only three
moments of Marvel Comics when he's ever
been cool uh when he basically like
speaks right and literally says actually
I have a better idea I take the body and
your people die so that my people can
live now here's the reason why that
matters and it catches the entirety of
the Illuminati off guard because Black
Bolt has a quasi-sonic screen that's the
reason he doesn't talk because if you
were to talk he'd probably kill
everybody in the room but the fact that
Black Bolt can speak without basically
putting off for really just releasing
his voice tells him right off the bat
that's not black bull but even that
realization is irrelevant because as
soon as it happens he basically lets off
an enormous amount of energy that
doesn't really kill everybody here but
certainly incapacitates them for a
moment and takes them off guard now of
course they're basically shielded just
because of their insanely fast reactions
but this scroll and it's one of the cool
things about it because this scroll had
replaced Black Bolt remember when the
secret Invasion project was undertaken
by the scroll Empire they have the
ability to mix and match Powers however
they see fit so they could literally
create a scroll or give the abilities to
a scroll that has the powers of
Spider-Man and Wolverine all rolled into
one if they chose to in this instance
because this scroll is infiltrating the
Illuminati it has all the powers of the
Illuminati it's got the telepathy of
Charles Xavier the strength of name of
the Submariner the elasticity of uh of
Reed Richards like it has all those
things right even the quasi-sonic scream
of Blackboard of course in this instance
it can control the scream instead of it
controlling him but where you end up
having Professor Xavier that tries to
use this telepathy on this guy and order
to bring it down it doesn't work right
like Xavier's telepathy does not work at
all and in fact this guy is able to
provide a telepathic feedback loop
that's basically two brick walls
smashing into each other but the scroll
is able to overcome it and Xavier is
temporarily incapacitated which by the
way for those of you guys who are
curious how it is that Professor Xavier
is walking basically when he came back
after the events of House of M he had
regained his ability to walk there's the
answer to your question so the thing
behind this and what's really crazy here
is Doctor Doom encases this guy in the
Crimson bands of sidorak which he's able
to break out of right this guy's
strength is on a whole different level
and so ultimately name of the Submariner
breaks this guy's neck and then throws
him onto a piece of rebar and basically
just kills him on the spot right now of
course this pisses off Iron Man and then
because it's like okay like this guy had
information but what we end up finding
out is this is not the only one like him
in fact there's multiple Scrolls who are
basically agents there to take out the
Illuminati all of whom are just as
capable as that guy is and so with the
group struggling against one having to
face off against two or three is even
more complicated than that and there's
no real discernment way for the group to
make it out alive so Iron Man does the
only thing he can do because of the fact
that this fight with that first scroll
had depleted his energy down to like 20
something percent and his suit was not
able to maintain he tells the Illuminati
to get out of there as fast as they
possibly can he Taps into a nearby
nuclear reactor like he literally
supercharges his armor and then just
lets off all this atomic energy in a
massive blast now the funny thing about
this is no one knew that Iron Man can do
that this is one of those instances when
the Iron Man is basically given a new
power that we never saw before so it is
cool to be able to see him tap into a
nuclear reactor absorb all that nuclear
energy and then let it off in the form
of what's effectively a small scale like
a small yield nuclear warhead it's
pretty awesome to see because he's
basically now a walking talking nuclear
bomb so that's kind of nuts but Iron Man
also says like the Scrolls didn't know
that I could do that either but now they
do and now that they do know it won't
work twice it's not going to work again
this is kind of Marvel's way of saying
like you're never going to see this
power again in Marvel Comics at least
not in the form of this story but
important thing here and what's really
crazy is Xavier picked up on something
that when Xavier tried to read the mind
of that scroll he came to this
realization that yes the scroll
Replacements are duplicates if you want
him call him that were able to dodge the
abilities of like Spider-Man and
Wolverine and being able to detect that
they were actual Scrolls but they can
also Dodge the telepathic abilities of
telepaths indirectly and the reason why
is because telepaths basically rely on
of course the mental patterns the
thoughts you have going on in your head
to understand what's happening here but
what Xavier says is that scroll believed
he was Black Bolt like that scroll
legitimately thought he was blackballed
and in turn turned against all of us now
of course in that moment when that
scroll turned against them its true
thoughts became manifested its true
thoughts were real but what Xavier
saying here is that when they all came
together in the first place and Xavier
was reading the thoughts of Black Bolt
before he turned before he revealed
himself as a scroll in order to know
what Black Bolt was thinking in their
meeting as far as Xavier was aware that
was Black Bolt so until such a time as a
scroll reveals their true motivations
and and actually activate themselves and
reveal themselves as a scroll and stop
being the person they're pretending to
be there's no conceivable way for a
telepath to know that it's actually a
scroll that's why this is a secret
Invasion that's why the secret Invasion
event even happened in the first place
because there's no way for the
superheroes on Earth to basically detect
that a person is an actual scroll what
this does is it basically starts to
destroy the trust between the members of
the Illuminati which had already walked
a knife set right they already came
together but they did it because they
felt like they had to not because they
truly wanted to and because that trust
was already so flimsy in the first place
now that they're all facing this
situation where the reality is any of
them could be a scroll there's no way to
know for sure name where the Submariner
is the first one to be like I don't
trust any of you here and he leaves and
that sows the seeds of Doubt among the
rest of the team because while they
don't openly come out and say it it's
literally the standoff at the end of The
Good the Bad and the Ugly they're all
just kind of looking at each other and
it's like are you a school I don't know
are you a scroll like it's a more
serious version of like the Spider-Man
meme that's basically what this is and
so ultimately even if only for a
temporary moment the entirety of the
Illuminati seemingly disband with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end thank you all for
watching and I will catch you all later
peace